welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy with ghost puns so bad
you'll just say
boo the hoarding of bly manor is now out
on netflix
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down all of the background
ghosts in the season
we've binged the entire series from
beginning to end and put together a full
list of every time one pops up in the
background
so definitely make sure you stay until
the end of the video obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't seen the season yet
then i highly recommend that you
you go into the lake and get the hell
out of here without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so for this video we're not going
to be covering the more obvious ones
such as all of the appearances by dany's
ex-fiancee
this list is purely reserved for the
more my new details
and from the off the season is
absolutely packed
the first episode actually has more
ghosts in it than all the other episodes
put together and the first one we get
comes at the 21 minute mark
when we see the characters walking up
the stairs stood
just to the right of the staircase is
the plague doctor ghost
who plagues this episode popping up at
several points
this ghost was actually used in the
promotional image for this season
with it appearing under an archway in
the photo for the mana
the character reappears a mere minute
later when miles
or rather quint pops up in dany's room
in the mirror we can see the doctor
standing there once more
and the character is gone when the
camera cuts about the rest of the scene
so we know that this was definitely him
he sure gets around
and one of the more subtle moments comes
at the 22 minute and 30 second mark
when we can see the ghost standing
beside miles it's extremely subtle
but we know that this is definitely the
figure once more as he's not there when
everyone gets up
at 26 16 there's also dany's ex-fiance
which appears for a split second as she
wipes the mirror
i didn't know whether to include this or
not but it's so brief that it just flies
by
and i think a lot of people will have
missed it at the 27-22 mark
we can once more see the plague doctor
standing in the doorway
the doctor is not there beforehand even
in the shots we get over dany's shoulder
which clearly shows that the space
beside the doorway is empty
a figure of the ghost also appears in
the dollhouse just after this moment
and it teases to the audience that we
need to keep an eye out for him
30 seconds later dany picks up the doll
off the floor
and when we cut to the mirror we can
once more see the doctor standing in the
reflection
the next bit is a bit difficult to make
out but at the 29 12 mark
as dany tucks flora in we can see over
her shoulder that the plague doctor is
there in the shadows
initially i was unsure over this but he
does move
ever so slightly so he can indeed
confirm it
confirm it's just perfectly splendid
when you crap your pants
now at the 31 59 mark as dany walks
towards the kitchen
we can also see the doctor standing to
the left of her in the shadows
cut to a minute later and danny walks
out of the kitchen
and we realize that it's been standing
there in the forefront the entire time
this is probably the most obvious one as
the character moves
and it lets us know to keep an eye out
for him at the 3442 mark
we can see what looks to be a tree
behind dany however
when we cut back to this shot later in
the conversation we can see that it's in
fact gone
confirming that this was the doctor when
the group are all sitting together in
the kitchen
we can also spot the character kneeling
down in the fireplace
watching over them as they eat he next
appears at the 44 50 mark
when dany goes to tuck flora in we can
see through her bedroom doorway into the
hall
and there he is standing against the
wall when dany kicks the doll
and then picks it up we can also see the
doctor in the mirror for a split second
it's a blink and you'll miss a moment
but it works really well to subliminally
let us know that he's always there
shortly after this miles enters the room
and we can see it standing there against
the wall between the two bedrooms
dany then goes to look in the cupboard
and though not initially there when she
enters
we can see the figure standing at the
back of the room just before she's
locked in there
the final one in the episode appears at
the 49-57 mark when dany goes into the
hallway down the bottom of it we can see
the doctor once more
clearly standing there and he's making
me
absolutely hate my life now if you're
all doctored out at this point
don't worry because episode 2 had some
more ghosts in
namely the child that can be seen at the
bottom of the hallway at the 6
25 mark at 2605 we can also see a quite
menacing looking figure under the window
of the house
as owen brings out the drinks for the
ladies also
i don't know if this is the best place
to mention it but you might notice that
throughout the first couple of episodes
at least
whenever hannah is offered food a drink
she comes up with an excuse not to have
it
the character is later revealed to be a
ghost and this is a nice bit of subtle
foreshadowing which
gives away that something is not right
with her now at 36
56 i don't know how danny doesn't spot
this but when playing hide and seek with
the children
she walks into one of the rooms and
right there in front of her
eye line is the plague doctor once more
shout out to my wife for spotting this
very obvious one
jump over to episode 3 and at 7 30
we can see a soldier standing right
under the stairs as hannah talks to the
policeman about calling mr wingrave
the character actually pops up a lot
throughout this episode and at the 12 51
mark he appears in the church against
the wall
it's very hard to make out but we've
boosted the brightness so you can see
him
at the 2006 mark he appears in the
kitchen standing to the far right of the
screen
but you'll only catch him when the
lightning flashes at 30 46
we can see the ghost of the child again
standing in the hallway
as dany walks about again it's difficult
to make out
but it's definitely there at the 3250
mark dany enters flora's room looking
for her
and she moves past a mirror in the
reflection we can actually see the
little boy's head
and it moves around as dany leaves the
room
at 34 51 we can catch the ghost of the
soldier
standing at the bottom of the corridor
finally at 37
22 when hannah and owen are in the
kitchen together you can spot the plague
doctor in the pantry
standing right at the back of it episode
4 is where they really start to turn the
hidden ghosts down
i think as certain elements take more of
a focus they tend to move away from this
however at the 1431 mark we can see a
well-dressed victorian figure
standing under the staircase where the
soldier was last time
it's difficult to make out who this is
but their bright white socks
really give it away now at 49-28 as dany
burns her ex-fiance's glasses
we can also see a figure standing
further back in the garden
looking over here in episode 5 at the
1033 mark
there appears to be a figure standing to
the right of the stairs
and though i'm not sure exactly who this
is i think it's one of the creepiest out
of the entire list
at 3046 when hannah is sat talking to
owen we can also see the creepy doll
standing against the wall to the right
of her that's all of the ghosts that i
could find in episode 5
but in episode 6 at the 1412 mark we can
see the soldiers standing sideways in
the cupboard when flora's mother is
trying to prove to her that there's
nothing there
there is something there fake news now
at 2040 when hannah and danny go into
flora's room
we can actually see a faceless figure
standing in miles doorway
the final one in the episode comes at
the hour and three minute mark
when dany runs up the stairs to the
attic in episode 7
we only get the one but at the 27-23
mark
when quinn is talking to rebecca we can
see that over her shoulder in the
doorway
there's a dark figure standing behind
her the final one for the series comes
at the 52-39 mark in episode 8
and as the lady of the lake viola enters
the body of water
in the smug behind her we can catch what
looks like a figure cloaked in the mist
that's actually the last one for the
entire series
and by the few jump scares and the
reflections for dany
there's actually very few ghosts in
episode nine
however the season does still have some
cooler easter eggs in it
in episode one when dany enters a room
we can see that the number on it is two
one seven
this is actually a reference to the
shining book which flanagan is a huge
fan of
the room was changed to 237 for the film
because the hotel thought that people
wouldn't stay in the 217 suite
if they believed it was haunted
personally that would that would be the
only room i would book out
and flanagan would of course go on to
direct the sequel of both the book and
film
dr sleep which is one of my favorite
horrors of the last 10 years
at the 30 minute mark of episode 1 we
also see dany sat on her bed with a head
in her hands
the posture of this makes her neck look
out of shape and i believe that it's
been done on purpose to reference the
bent neck lady from the first season
she was played by the same actress
behind dany i think that flanagan put
this in place
as a cool little nod to the prior entry
anyway
that's all of them and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the series
and if we missed any of the ghosts then
make sure you comment below and let us
know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of all the hidden
ghosts and things you missed in the
haunting of hill house which is going to
be linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below the winners are
going to be chosen on the 30th of
october
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat
who's on the discord server linked in
the description
on heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul the
headless houseman
and i'll see you next time take care
peace
these puns just so bad every time
[Music]
you